With each generation a new catwoman emerges from
the shadows for director matt reeves the batman
presented the perfect opportunity to reimagine the
complex character of selena kyle the villains are
often you know some of the most if not the most
exciting part of the movies i mean the rogues
gallery is incredible and what i wanted to do was
i wanted to see a batman that was not an origin
tale but was sort of in these early days but that
meant that a lot of the characters who are the
rogues gallery characters are in their origins
in a way and so we have a selena kyle who's
not yet catwoman selena can take care of herself
she's incredibly tough she really wants to fight
for those who don't have someone else to fight
for them and i think that is where batman and
she really connect what's most interesting about
selena kyle is that she represents the savior
for the ill-treated the forgotten the people
that have not had anybody looking after them
she's also very complicated you don't quite know
exactly where her loyalty or her allegiance lie
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
batman movie video matt reeves dc just released
this new clip about the batman movie talking
about the rogues gallery of villains talking
about batman talking about catwoman there's
a whole bunch of really big stuff coming up
for the movie so be sure to subscribe to get
everything of course i'll be doing videos for
all years they continue to release new trailers
but if you're not sure what's going on with this
this is actually part of a larger big documentary
about the catwoman character in general but they
used it to talk about a lot of what's going on
in the new matt reeves in robert pattinson batman
movies i believe you can watch a version of this
like the larger catwoman documentary if you have
any of the first four batman movies starting
with michael keaton's batman i believe it's
part of the bonus features but this is a
tiny portion taken from a much larger thing
but the really cool thing is you have matt reeves
talking about his inspiration for doing the movie
with the younger version of batman earlier in
his career and by default that also meant that
the core rogues gallery of villains all the big
characters had to be at the same point in their
evolution so if it wasn't clear this is meant to
be batman year two during the events of the film
there is a batman hbo spin-off series that he's
doing with gordon and some of the other bigger
batman movie characters that'll be premiering
sometime next year i believe but that's actually
meant to be batman year one it's just when people
think about batman early in his career usually the
first thing they go to is frank miller's batman
year one because that was such a good story but
as matt reeves says he didn't want to do another
origin story because christopher nolan just did
batman begins so that's that's why he chose to do
it as batman year two so he's been batman for a
little while that's why you see the version of his
costume still kind of looks like a prototype of
what will eventually evolve into something that
looks closer to say like ben affleck's batman
costume with a much older version of batman
that also means he doesn't have the classic
bat cave yet like this is meant to be a different
version and all the other classic rogues gallery
of villains have not fully become their characters
from the comics yet like nobody's wearing a fully
comic book accurate costume but it does look like
some of them are inspired by classic versions of
the costumes the timeline in the comics is
a little bit different for the way batman
evolves with the cape and cowl in the way his
rogues gallery of villains evolves and how he
encounters them across the years but the way matt
reeves and the other people behind the movie talk
about batman in this film most of the regular
citizens of gotham city have heard about a guy
dressed up as about running around the past year
beating up criminals at night because it has been
a year we're in batman year two but most of
the people like the average people in gotham
don't totally buy that it's a real thing like
they just think that it's all lies in the press
and the rest of the people in the city that do
believe in him aren't really sure what to make of
him whether he's friend or foe or just an agent of
chaos to make a christopher nolan joker reference
i will talk about the joker later in the video
because he is supposed to exist within the world
of this version of batman which is supposed to be
earth 2 by the way matt reeves clarified last year
at dc fandom that his batman movies will take
place in an alternate universe from the main
justice league movies to explain how this version
of batman can exist in present day but also be way
younger they'll be using the concept of the
multiverse in the flash movie to sort of sew
everything together with all the disparate parts
that don't completely make sense on their own
but a version of the joker is meant to exist in
the world of matt reeves batman apparently though
he's not really going to be featured in a big
way during this first new batman movie i think
just because there's been so much joker lately
between heath ledger's joker which obviously
was amazing in the dark knight jared leto's joker
and the suicide squad more recently in the justice
league snyder cut and then joaquin phoenix's joker
movie there was even a hollywood reporter article
where they claimed that inside warner brothers
there still talks about doing a sequel to joaquin
phoenix's joker movie but the way todd phillips
was talking about it more recently he said that if
that was going to happen it was going to be a good
long while so i would say if they do a sequel to
that film we won't see it for like another three
or four years bare minimum but all the classic
rogues gallery villains are meant to exist within
the world of this new matt reeves batman movie and
as he says they're all just going through their
early days too but matt reeves goes so far as
to say that during the events of this film selena
kyle has not become catwoman yet even though she's
clearly wearing a very step down prototype of a
catwoman suit which i think is partially meant
to be inspired by the classic catwoman suit i
think what he means is that she's just doing
catwoman things in the film but no one is calling
her catwoman and she doesn't call herself she
doesn't think of herself as catwoman she's just
running around stealing things trying to help
people in the streets as zoe kravitz talks about
the character she says her version of catwoman is
trying to fight for people who don't have anyone
i guess that goes hand in hand with the idea that
most people in the city at least at this point
in the timeline batman year two don't believe
that either batman exists or if they do believe
he exists don't think that he's fighting for them
i think that's what's meant to happen by the end
of this film like the whole idea that batman isn't
sure how he's connected to this larger mystery
that the riddler is trying to throw at him like
the riddler is trying to call out batman trying to
force him to get rid of all this corruption in the
city whereas at the beginning of the film he comes
off as more of a villain killing the mayor here
i'll talk about him in a second too because the
whole idea is that the riddler is going through
his origin story and starts out as more of an
anti-hero character at least with a good idea that
just really poor in its execution like wanting to
get rid of a corrupt mayor corruption in the city
but also going around killing people to do it
so as they talk about the cow woman character
and obviously the riddler character he's presented
the funny thing is is they are trying to do good
things but they don't have any real interest in
being good people it's just that they hate the
really really rotten people in the city and they
want to get rid of them but through their own
actions eventually some of them wind up becoming
really big powerful villains in the city like the
classic versions of the comic book characters the
new footage of her inside the cemetery seems like
it's from the same scenes we saw them filming
earlier this year with both batman and catwoman
driving into the cemetery on their motorcycles
and this scene of her inside the tomb with the cat
i think it's just implied by her voiceover that
she's just thinking about all these dead people
and the people on the street that she's trying to
help i did try to find easter eggs in these names
and none of them are big dc comics characters so i
don't think they're meant to be super significant
other than just to make her think about what she's
doing and why she's doing it the cemetery itself
seems fairly significant during the film like
you see the separate footage of batman driving
at night into the cemetery in what seems like a
separate scene also entering his current version
of the bat cave so even though the bat cave seems
like it's an abandoned subway station or train
station hall it might be near the cemetery
like the entrance might be near the cemetery
and separately batman tends to visit the cemetery
on a pretty regular basis to visit his parents
graves so it just seems like the cemetery itself
will be a big location during the film very dark
very gothic very in the tone of a batman movie i
think the idea in the clip when they talk about
catwoman as an anti-hero like you're not meant to
know where her loyalty lies obviously that's just
keeping with the tone of her character in the
comics in the context of the movie i think that's
her just not completely trusting batman when they
cross paths and not wanting to completely throw
in with characters like the penguin or the other
criminals in the city like falcone a lot of the
movie as you can see from the trailer footage
is inspired by batman the long halloween story
but in this scene here you see batman catcher and
the actor trying to steal from what seems like a
rich person's house but in the comic book version
of the story bruce wayne is actually dating selena
kyle at the very beginning but neither one of them
knows each other's secret identity because they're
still relatively early in their careers they
attend a party that's being thrown by carmine
falcone and at the party separately carmine
tries to compel bruce wayne to launder his
billions of dollars through mob controlled banks
he obviously turns them down but they also find
out that their friend harvey dent is there being
beaten up by falcone's men because he's trying to
prosecute falcone they save him but then later
batman comes back in full costume to actually
investigate falcone's penthouse so that they
can find more evidence to actually convict him
and catches catwoman in the act of stealing from
his save so i think the idea is that the mayor was
corrupt and the riddler was trying to out him but
there's also a lot of police corruption because
that's a big theme in batman's stories and the
riddler wants to do something about it he's just
going about it in a very batman villain kind of
way so that's what i say what i mean a lot of the
batman villains in matt reeves rogues gallery are
meant to start out more as anti-heroes like he's
trying to show clear motivation on their part like
they start out as normal people who are driven
to extremes and wind up becoming villains through
their own actions and just the way they present
catwoman at least in this clip and talk about
her i think the idea in the movie is that she's
really only stealing things robin hood style like
she's only stealing from really bad rich people
her whole connection to carmine falcone like you
see them at the mayor's funeral here together i
believe she believes that he's really her father
but eventually in the comics it's found out that
her father wound up being somebody totally
different it's not super clear what that means
for colin farrell's version of the penguin and his
origin story because he's not meant to be the main
villain of this film in the way that most of the
story focuses on batman and the riddler's story
the way they're presenting him in the footage he
seems more like a mid-level criminal with a small
group around him operating similar to what
you'd see from some of the mob characters or
maybe this earlier version the character does
have ties to the mob at this point in history
as for the joker the way they've talked about him
so far at least the rumors is that it's going to
be more of a batman begin situation like they'll
tease him there'll be some references to him in
the first movie but he won't be featured in a
big way the same way in batman begins no one
ever said the name the joker gordon just whips
out the playing card and says this might be a
thing and batman says i'll check it out and i
just let you know that the joker was coming but
let me know in the comments who you'd want to be
that new version of the joker within this universe
once they work up to him leave all your big dc
video requests in the comments below there's a
bunch of loki episodes that i'll be doing videos
for they'll be starting really soon so make sure
you have alerts enabled so you don't miss anything
everyone click here for that brand new big marvel
phase 4 trailer video in the eternals trailer and
click here for my full breakdown of the entire
plot of the justice league snyder cut 2 in justice
league 3 movies that zack snyder had planned out
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!